anyone who's seen marvel studios loki
knows that we are exploring new corners
of the mcu which is why i'm speaking
with bfx supervisor brad parker hey brad
hey there
so let's speak a little bit about the
time variance authority it's the first
new location we get to see loki in how
would you describe the overall aesthetic
of the tva well the tva has this really
cool sort of retro futuristic look to it
there are elements of sort of analog
technology and early 1980s digital
technology mixed with a few technologies
that are very much from the future so
that's sort of mashed together into this
very unique aesthetic but has this kind
of patina of being something that may
have happened in the past even though
the size scope and scale of it feels
like it must be in the future
it really is appropriately a timeless
look and you can really see that in the
expanse at the tva how do you take
actors and put them into a shot like
that everything beyond the window that
loki and mobius are standing in front of
was created digitally on set we had a
hallway and a window frame and our
actors were able to look out into a blue
screen but everything beyond that was
created entirely in the computer
so then once you have all of those
elements how do you build out the
expanse with your team so building
something like the expanse takes
a lot of artists building a lot of
individual elements that can run
anywhere from the basic architecture
meaning the sort of columns and posts
and walls that comprise the structures
inside the expanse but also atmospheric
effects like clouds and fog and little
vehicles flying around an insane amount
of detail goes into creating something
like the expanse
another place that we see that immense
detail is at the archives of the tva
what kind of work goes into filling out
that space yeah so the archives are
really interesting um production
actually filmed in a a real hotel in
atlanta and the archives were sort of an
extension of that so that's a good
example of digital set extensions where
we started with a real place but the
real place wasn't as large and you know
it didn't create this kind of infinite
archive feel but it did give us a really
good guide as to what the architecture
would be and what sort of the palette of
the space would be so we were able to
kind of riff off of that
and build something much larger much
more infinite looking based on that kind
of real world practical photography and
that's something that i would add is
that when you're able to mix
real places with visual effects the
results are often very very believable
it's a great way to work so could you
talk us through the layers that pull
together that whole shot when we're
creating a digital set extension we'll
get what's called a plate and a plate is
basically the photography with no visual
effects and will match the lens so
anything that we build digitally looks
like it was photographed by the
cinematographer the next step would be
to add a 3d model that represents the
architecture and details things like you
know all the books on the bookshelves
for example all of those details are
combined together into a shot that's
then composited
absolutely incredible but now let's fast
forward to the end of the series where
we go on this epic journey to the
citadel what goes into bringing that
kind of sequence to life so in order to
create this travel through time and
space um we started with a rough guide
that the editorial department put
together this was a series of clips and
pre-visualizations of the sort of travel
experience you know which planets we
would pass by which black holes we
travel through and how long the entire
sequence might take so based on that our
team of digital artists started to
create sort of space geography those
structures the material that we travel
through the black holes that we travel
through and kind of place them all out
into a sequence that's then sort of
approved by the director and and our
editors once that is all approved we
work on refining it and making it look
believable and realistic so in this case
it's creating sort of gaseous space
elements and you know believable planets
and the timeline itself the sacred
timeline which all kind of ends at the
citadel where he who remains resides the
process for creating that was really to
kind of sculpt what this planetoid would
be like in three dimensions and we built
the citadel all the architecture you
know every last brick to put the place
together in the computer and place that
on top of the citadel and that was a
sort of creation that was based on some
conceptual art that was drawn by a very
talented artist and our team of digital
artists kind of built that or realized
it in 3d ultimately it's all rendered
and composited together to be one
seamless experience
that moment is such a big whirlwind are
there any little details that our marvel
fans might have missed that you could
clue us in on so you know there was a
hidden detail or two there are a few
little elements that we pass by one
might be the collector's ship um
can't confirm nor deny that and there
may be one or two that are worth kind of
scrubbing through slowly and seeing if
you can pick out ooh you know i'm gonna
do that now as you look back at the
conclusion of this epic series what are
you most proud of so i'd say the thing
that i'm most proud of
is kind of working with this team of
incredible artists who
all had to work from a home you know
because of uh coveted lockdown together
everyone was able to create something
that's absolutely stunning and beautiful
everybody really stepped up and worked
as hard as they possibly could and i'm
just really proud of the team and
everything they did to make this
beautiful series oh that's so lovely
thank you so much brad and of course
everyone go watch marvel studios loki
all episodes are now streaming only on
disney plus